[Music]
let me know if this is good news or bad
news to you because it almost feels like
a mixture of both i think everything is
good news okay this will really fit in
great with your opinion the taliban are
now banning tiktok in afghanistan
because they think that it misleads the
younger generation wow hey that's
they're onto something have you guys
heard the theory of it's china's way of
taking us down yeah where the algorithm
favors like very low iq content yeah so
like if we like it and that gets more
views then it encourages the kids to do
more dumb [ __ ] and encourage the view so
it's a cycle of making our entire
younger generation stupid and stupid
that's so genius if that's real
their tick tock it's like if kids are
talking about engineering
likes go up if they're talking about
like political philosophical stuff their
likes go up so it's like so their
algorithm is way different than our
american algorithm how come chinese tick
tock always got some chinese farm person
cooking some dope ass [ __ ] because they
need people to be farmers yeah
dude no wonder what about the pant what
about the panda guy that's running
around what's the panda guy do like he's
just like a panda suit running around
like hitting people that's funny that's
hilarious it says chinese unless it's
like chinese produced content throwing
at us yeah then i'm like i don't like it
yeah because i like it there's a weird
part of chinese tick tock that just
keeps popping up on my ship and it's
like well it's not even tick tock it's
like reals right but i think it's
reuploaded from tick-tock but there's
like these tall like chinese like
fashion girls that just like oh yeah
they slow-mo they slo-mo walk and
there's like a
[ __ ] huge line of dudes just with
photos taking pictures of them what's
like yeah what's what's that one song
that one song
[Laughter]
we all know the words yeah on tick tock
people like doing the slow-mo walking
guys and girls i've seen people do that
stuff like like these uh like the white
boys with the hair that like swooshes up
and they always have those other shirts
style by the way i've been meaning to
ask you oh i'm not i can't wear it so i
can't i'm not a fan oh this straight
hair little way can get a curl through
this you definitely can't you just gotta
get like uh you know it's possible
that's not natural i have to get a perm
yeah a micro perm is that what it's
called no can you hook me up with that
kit just for you i think the old roman
style is coming back do you think if
like dance crews were still a thing
there'd be like a whole crew of guys
with that same haircut maybe yeah
they don't have dance who's going balls
dance cruise right no
not really huh yeah now everyone's like
individually doing something because
it's more it's more financially like
plausible to just be a soloist yeah
because a tick-tock dude tick-tock
ruined vertical frame
guys in that good luck
yeah it's not gonna work so yeah they're
banning uh tick tock i wonder what the
taliban ticket would look like if they
had yeah what's their algorithm [ __ ]
on a pedal swan with guns probably yeah
yeah dude that's probably their most
viral video by flying yeah but they
think that it's uh
misleading the younger generation
because there's probably hot chicks on
there yeah imagine going on a taliban
tick tock and it's just all hot asian
girls like no wonder dude yeah that's
true
they're going to all want to leave to
china
damn yeah that's why yeah they might be
like man the western world is really
awesome
girls dress like this
i really believe the thing you said
about how their their algorithms geared
differently for other countries like if
they could just make american generation
become nothing but influencers and then
their generation like they they exalt
like people with jobs or careers or like
i know they become rocket scientists and
[ __ ] yeah but you know what's great
about america is we've been stupid and
the the whole appeal here is they learn
all that [ __ ] out there and then we take
all the engineers because they want to
run away to america yeah they want to
come here yeah let's just let china
india all these guys just [ __ ] do all
the money and get as smart as possible
yeah then we're just on tick-tock
and then they're gonna be like one day
i'm gonna be smart as [ __ ] so i myself
can get an american twerking woman
that's the that's the trophy that's the
trophy everybody wants a twerking
american woman as a wife
because there's just so much variety
here yeah like as in like
it could be a black why asia but there's
every ethnicity every choice for every
human being you know like just like
you're ready to go that's true and now
it's even more diverse where hey maybe
it's a man that you want or maybe it's a
buying non-binary trans or something
different you want there's every option
for everybody everything and then
there's a chinese engineer out there
that's going you know i've always wanted
a non-binary twerking person
and where do you find that at you can't
do it in china that's bad
an engineer do you guys all have a tick
tock i don't know i have an account but
i don't post on it yeah i don't don't i
try to stay away from it because i'm
like if i go on that app i see like all
my friends even like my ladies she's
like scrolling all the time and she's
like yo i'm like i'm addicted to like
two hours bam i'm going like that well
it's like and i i know if i have that my
position
it's over bro so i don't even go on it i
can't i love chinese farmers uh showing
off their crop like the big mangoes and
then they'll be having a whole [ __ ]
mango display and i'm like that's so
wasteful you got like 50 open mangoes
and [ __ ] and then you get an ice cream
scooper and you scoop the mango and you
like look at it i know man i want that
album
i think it depends on how you uh like
your videos and what you watch longer
right and the algorithm goes oh you like
this but like if you have like stuff you
really like like philosophy tick tock or
like [ __ ] anime ticked out or like
things you actually like it's like cool
i'll look at it once in a while but i
won't get addicted to it but i think the
people that are getting addicted to it
are watching the trending [ __ ] and
they're just hooked on that yeah
but if you
actually curate what you like you're
you're just gonna view it like oh cool
this is what's happening in the [ __ ]
anime world cool and then you it's
impossible because tick tock will still
suggest things right variety so you're
on
up to
yeah you you like like four philosophy
ones right then the bouncing booty comes
on you're like oh oh and you click on it
yeah that's a great stimulus one
bouncing booty two bouncing booty three
bouncy and then oh where's all my
philosophers go it comes it comes around
though it comes around that that's
that's the thing because i purposefully
tried to do that and i was sick of like
every time i open my instagram in front
of my girl like it's gonna be ass yeah
it's gonna make me look like i'm [ __ ]
jerking all day yeah yeah so i tried to
sing it to you yeah i know so i tried to
like un like i'd be like don't want to
see that don't want to see that i did it
for like months how do you click you
don't want to see it my feet my three
dots my feed finally became nothing but
cars rabbits and uh video games finally
[ __ ] because it knew that i'm a guy and
it's like yeah but you're gonna like it
you're gonna like it
it's because it's not always what you
have but it's who you following your
friends
that too that's who yeah yeah if your
lines are pervert
you're gonna it's gonna taint everybody
dude mine is like asian girls chihuahuas
which one's which
[Laughter]
just those two you only get that's a
pale chihuahua chihuahuas oh yeah asian
girls and chihuahuas it's very specific
mine's gonna be [ __ ]
oh man two things i love most oh my god
terrible how do i even i don't even know
what this is okay
i got trucks memes motorcycles girls and
chinese
peasant boys packing things like noodles
mine's a german shepherd wearing a hat
dude that's pretty accurate right and
then a [ __ ] ton of mma [ __ ] this is this
is mine all right there's a dr pimple
popper i don't really watch much of that
but it's interesting uh some muay thai
though bruh
has boula and then this giant iranian
dude and then like some other fish on
brand i would say i'm surprised my
[ __ ] fee doesn't have more women
it used to have
mine has a free cane velasquez shirt for
sale
you do believe in that cause this i do
actually a bunch of scripts unusual ocd
obsessions
you cannot co-parent with a narcissist
yeah fitness fitness tattoo stuff that
could pop oh interesting i guess i
really like dogs
i have a golden retriever eating a
baguette and then the other dog trying
to eat it from him and he's like no
mine's all girls video games bunnies and
then vanilla ice got a little baby
you got a baby you like it i'm actually
kind of worried how much bullet stuff i
have
i think that's great i get a lot of
husband yeah dude joe sends me hospital
the videos [ __ ] ryan sends me all the
house bullet videos if this was your
feed as a teenager exactly the same [ __ ]
do you would you feel like you're being
misled
what just hot chicks after more and more
if you could talk to your teenage self
and they and this was what your teenage
self was gonna be seeing would you think
hey you're going the wrong way or would
you would it be totally acceptable
mine's all right it's just like mma dogs
fitness yeah cars
that's like similar to me that looks
like michael jackson
look i was just scrolling i'm just
looking at our contacts
yeah now i'm just like
wait what is this rabbit doing it was
too good
he's in the vortex you gotta pull him
out
you know we're getting sucked in
yeah
pretty crazy because sometimes i'll wake
up right i'll wake up and i'm like all
right i got like five minutes to kill so
i'll just be in bed i'm just like
scrolling around and then i'm like oh
[ __ ] that was 30 minutes yeah yeah i try
not to do that when i wake up i just
don't i don't go on that's the hardest
challenge you win that challenge for the
day what do you do what's the first day
when you wake up then i go brush my
teeth you get out of bed yeah i get up
yeah i don't i try not to do that or go
on i hold my breath and do push-ups
really hold it as soon as you wake up i
just one of the methods i have several
you up minutes yeah because i need to i
realize that that half a sleep state
um you know like our minds so like for
example right when you're in the zone
your mind's at a i call it a different
frequency because you're just firing at
a higher rate but that for me that
moment of waking up to feeling fully
awake my mind is [ __ ] dude because i'm
like a nightmare zone or like half a
sleep zone or like i'm like awake by
physically awake but i'm not like alert
so then like my mind thinks scattered
negative paranoid whatever right
or like i'll wake up with like crazy
shock like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] tiger's
chasing me and then i'm like in a hotel
room or like whatever so i had to figure
out how to snap out of it quicker
so then i did uh like i would do like
wim hof breathing i tried that i just
jump into the cold shower that works um
i would just get up put on some shorts
and run around the block that works so
anything that can like get my body
moving
physically that works a lot but then the
easiest thing was to like
like move over hold my breath and just
start doing push-ups and i just yeah
just like just like do 20 and then stop
take another deep breath 20 i'm fully
awake what's the breath holding have to
do with it i think it's for adrenaline
oh it's to shock you yeah i usually do
the stuff and when i wake up too in the
morning
just move yeah or the wim hop breathing
oh yeah yeah that stuff is really really
good it's really good yeah dude this
morning i woke up like right before my
alarm i was telling him normally i was
supposed to wake up at eight right and i
woke up i was like oh [ __ ] it's 8 30 so
my body was just in shock like i have to
leave the house now but then i was like
wait a minute i'll get there on time so
i just went
and i just did a quick deep breath and
then tried to calm myself down because i
was like up here dude i was like holy
[ __ ] because you see how breath can
change
that level of anxiety for you yeah it
just completely like reset me and i was
like oh i'm on time you're like
underrated i wake up i hold my breath
too and i do breathing work and i go i
wonder what hospital is doing and i go
[Laughter]
he's eating burgers again
good man oh you're literally right
that's how you do it that's how you do
it hold your breath that's what tony
robbins does that's why he's so rich
yeah i read his book though do you watch
his hospital he's in the [ __ ] ice
bath every morning though like he's
strong
built into his house yeah he goes
straight into an ice bath it's like i
don't want to wake up to that oh my god
i'd rather wake up to a [ __ ] and then
i take a cold shower that's fine and
then you go back to sleep
what's your trick for falling asleep
though watching that oh i don't need no
tricks
he goes it just turns 7 30 pm and that's
it dude i knock out i can what's crazy
is like um
i just have to
think about something and then
you know like how improv show someone
gave me a place a location or whatever
right yeah when i'm sleeping when i'm
ready to sleep i go like this i just
need to have a thought about anything
that was your improv show red what if
it's a [ __ ] i can fall asleep to any
word in the audience
i'll think about literally anything okay
bread and then now
yeah that's floating in the sky it's
like wheat bread and now i'm dreaming
about bread and it's i'm instantly
within a dream in like
10 20 seconds that's the superpower this
is just the most lucid wheat loaf you've
ever had in your life and then it goes
and then it goes somewhere else and then
it goes somewhere else and then now i
don't even know
that but your mind wanders that's it
yeah yeah my mind wanders i'm sleeping
if you told me bread i'm like okay bread
wait sliced bread wasn't normal when did
that start hold on i need to [ __ ]
reese
[Music]
did slice bread come into the picture oh
wait white bread wasn't always something
we ate damn food i like you too though
like if a thought comes i just let it go
and then i just i just go to sleep just
drift yeah i just dripped into it y'all
some [ __ ] booty like
me and jill will get ready me and jill
get ready like um for bed
and then
i i knock out probably less than under a
minute and then later like i i still
feel the light or like the bed moves i'm
like oh [ __ ] and then it's like an hour
later and she's still trying to read a
book and [ __ ] i'm like damn it takes you
that long to fall
dude have you ever closed your eyes and
your mind is still awake and thinking
about stuff but then when you uh try to
open them you're like holy [ __ ] my body
feels tranquilized oh you'd be talking
about like the sleep paralysis no like
like it just feels super relaxed like
you're you're halfway to falling asleep
like you ever felt that oh but you we
were able to open your eyes during no no
you open your eyes and you wake up but
you're still your body was just about to
fall asleep oh that's that's a torturous
that's edgy dude yeah basically yeah
you're edging your sleep
yeah yeah that's not good that's a drug
like a sleeping pill or something
because your body's like kind of
awesome it's so hard for me to get to
that thing you're talking about once
your mind starts to flow into weird
realms and that's how you know you're
sleeping yeah it's hard for me to get
there because i i maintain logic too
long so the way that i [ __ ] force it
when i need to sleep is i think this has
worked for me my whole life i think of a
movie that i know so [ __ ] well and
that's always back to the future one
i watch it in my mind from the
intro credits and i try to get as far as
i can without my mind wandering without
fail my mind will wander your mind will
absolutely work
because if you [ __ ] up and you think of
something else and you straight for the
movie you gotta start over
so the idea that game the idea that you
have to start over is so stressful that
you're just like
[ __ ] this
it works great dude right when you see
robert zemeckis producer
[Music]